this is a quote by a physicist
as a comment on one of his experimental
results
he said about his experiment he said it
was as if you fired a 15-inch shell at a
piece of tissue paper
paper
and it came back and hit you
so let's talk about his experiment and
what he was doing
rutherford at the time had been doing
a lot of research on radioactivity
he was friends with marie curie and her
husband
pierre
and he had done a lot of studies
looking at the different kinds of
reactivity and more specifically
he was curious at this time
about alpha sorry alpha particles
which are he didn't actually at the time
he didn't know what they were but we now
know that they are helium two plus
nuclei so that means we have two protons
in the
nucleus since it's helium and it also
has two
neutrons
and it doesn't have any electrons and
thus thus it has a two plus charge
so what brethrefred did
he took a piece of radium and he put it
inside a lead box
and the lead box had a small hole in it
on one side
so that
the radio
active alpha particles
could come out of that hole in the
direction that he wanted
and then
he shot
the alpha particles at a piece of gold
foil
a very thin piece of gold foil
and he was curious to see
if he could learn a little bit about the
structure of the atom using this
experiment
so if we look back at our quote
we would say
that our
alpha particles here the alpha particles
are the
bullets
that are coming out of our alpha
particle gun
and
gold foil is our tissue paper
and we have these pretty fast and
massive alpha particles that we're
shooting at it
but why
was rutherford expecting expecting that
to happen here it's not necessarily
straightforward at least to me why you
would think these alpha particles would
just go straight through the gold foil
so what rutherford at the time was doing
was
he was testing the plum pudding model
so this is pretty early in history
where
we
we being scientists way back then knew
that
jj thompson another physicist had just
discovered electrons so we knew the atom
the atom had something
had these particles in it that were
small that were really small we knew
that they were
less than
one percent the mass of a hydrogen atom
so way smaller than atom
and we knew they were negatively charged
so i'm going to call them electrons
because we know there are electrons now
and so jj thompson
knew that
electrons existed based on his
experimental results and he proposed
based on his results that an atom
looks something like a plum pudding
and if you don't know what a plum
pudding is because maybe you're not
british or you just don't like dessert
um you can also imagine it looking
something like a chocolate chip cookie
so we have
these little
negatively charged particles that are
stuck inside the atom but most of the
atom
is made up of a positively charged soup
and
this was mainly because
the
atom overall has to be neutral
scientists knew that atoms were neutral
so there had to be something there to
cancel out the negative charge of the
electron
so because
rutherford was starting
with this in his mind for what the gold
atoms look like
he could actually do mathematical
predictions on what the alpha particles
would do and what he predicted was that
they would just go straight through
you can use physics equations
to look at the electric field
that's generated by this positively
charged soup and it turns out that the
field
because the charge is spread out all
over the atom the field is very weak
and so
what he thought would happen was that
all the particles would just go straight
through and then occasionally one of
them might be bent a little bit
since we do have
a positively charged soupy atom um
depending on where the
the alpha particles goes through he
thought you might see a little bit of
deflection but mostly they should go
straight through
and
i guess we started with a spoiler
because we know that well he didn't
quite get what he expected
so what exactly did rutherford see
well he shot his alpha particles as
tissue paper
and
he saw most of the particles go straight
through
just as he expected
in fact he saw
almost all the particles go straight
through he saw a couple of them
be deflected a little bit so they got
deflected off their path maybe about one
degree so barely enough to be able to
see it and
you know if he had
not been a curious chemist we would
maybe still think right now that
this is what an atom looks like
but luckily rutherford was a very
thorough chemist
and he also thought it might be
interesting to detect
whether
particles came
not just here he didn't just put a
detector screen here he put a detector
screen that went all the way around
which so all the way around almost all
the way around giving enough space for
the alpha particles to go in
and he
he was being really careful here because
he really didn't expect to see anything
right around here or here here or really
anywhere except for here but it turned
out that
for every
one in
one in 20 000
alpha particles or some crazy tiny
number like that
for every 1 in 20 000 alpha particles he
saw the particles hit the gold foil and
bounced back
and that's crazy right that's exactly
what you don't expect when you hit a
a piece of tissue paper with a bullet
so the first thing he did i think
was not go hmm this is really crazy we
just want a nobel prize here i'm pretty
sure the first thing he did was this is
weird and then he probably checked his
experimental results and he tried to
repeat it and he checked everything to
make sure nothing was going wrong
and
it turned out that
yes
something was actually happening this 1
in 20 000 alpha particles was real
so what what did this mean this meant
that we needed a new
atomic model
we had to explain somehow that a tiny
fraction of the alpha particles was
getting bounced back
so how did he do this he knew there was
something in the atom that was tiny
massive
and positively charged
and he knew that had to be tiny
because not very many alpha particles
interacted with it because most of them
went straight through
he knew that had to be massive and
positively charged because
well the electrons are really small
and
most of the particles went straight
through so whatever
these particles were interacting with
had to be very small
but really heavy
which is how they bounced right back
so he made a new
model of the atom that incorporated
these
requirements
and what he said
was that
there must be something in there with
these
properties which we now call the nucleus
and it's really tiny
in fact he was able to calculate exact
well not exactly he was able to
calculate approximately how big it was
based on how many alpha particles hit it
and he said it was approximately one
10 000
of the volume of the atom
and then what else do we have we know we
have this nucleus which is positively
charged and tiny and massive and then we
also have our electrons
and then what's the rest of the atom
doing based on all of this
that means most of the atom is actually
empty space
since the
electrons are really small and the
nucleus only takes up one ten thousandth
of the radius the rest of that space is
all just nothing which is kind of crazy
so based on this particular model that
rutherford makes made next
he was able to explain his results he
was able to explain that most of the
alpha particles just went straight
through and then every now and then an
alpha particle
would come really close to the nucleus
and then that would get deflected a
little bit
and even more rare an alpha particle may
hit a nucleus straight on and then it
would get bounced off because the
nucleus is super heavy and because it's
positively charged so it would repel the
positively charged alpha particle
rutherford called this particular model
or we call it now i'm not sure which
actually
he called it the nuclear model
this actually looks pretty similar to
the modern picture of the atom that most
people think of there's a lot of
questions that are still not answered
here like what exactly the electrons are
doing
or where are they
where are the electrons
but because
rutherford proposed this new model other
scientists were able to design new
experiments to test it
and not very long afterward we had a
pretty good picture of what was going on
on the level of the atom